so this is the the hack space blending
machine we bought this I believe off
eBay secondhand for about a hundred
pounds we ran a very successful pledge
drive when our first pledge drives for
it and it wasn't it was non-functional
came without a coin mechanism and there
was no way of actually using it but we
thought winner will work an Arduino in
it and make it work
everyone in hex base gets hungry we use
it to have food but also at the same
time people want to buy things bits and
pieces in the hack space so we have lots
of electronic kits that people can buy
wire hack space passports and people can
also buy tokens here to buy packs based
t-shirts or cans from the fridge in the
kitchen what it does let's do is it
let's just keep track of things and
allow members to buy things on ticks so
that if they don't got any money here
they can buy stuff and pay for it later
on how does it work
so when you open up it automatic test
itself off with a nice little button up
here and you'll see a nice big mess of
why is the first thing we did was we
bought in his sort of coin mechanism the
coin mechanism actually cost us more to
buy than the vending machine itself
because we had to buy a 2-byte fully
working because they're not user
serviceable in any way and that connects
to the main vending machine controller
which is in behind this panel here we
thought we'd have to hack into this in
some way to get the the RFID working
what actually turns out that the coin
mech connects to it on ER on a protocol
called multi drop boss or MDB which
already knows about cashless devices or
RFID cards so just hang on the minute
Tommy got from just buying a coin back
that cost more than vending machines
it's here RFID we wanted it to be able
to do both that was that was the whole
thing it always took me out to do both
so somebody could buy stuff on with it
with their cash in their pocket or they
could buy stuff with their RFID cards
because that's what they could do on the
old system where we had literally
chocolate shelves and a pot of money and
a board you could write your money on so
I wanted to have to do the whole shebang
the coin mech was actually whipped
buying it was controversial because we
didn't want to have to buy something but
luckily sanity about won out in the end
and we bought we bought the coin mech
and we installed out and got that
working and the main machine was in
theory was working fully working then
you could buy stuff from it fairly
easily but we didn't actually tell
anyone at that point we didn't want it
to be used because we were opened up all
the time to try and get the cashless
device working so this is our vending
machine controller and this is the
device that operates all the motors in
here make sure the thing
then now properly we found out from
looking at the speck that actually the
multi drop bus can have multiple devices
connected to it and already knows about
em cashless devices so all we have to do
is build a device that implemented that
specification and connect it up to the
vending machine
okay min the main machine that was all
there and then this is what we had done
so our cassius device is is based on an
Arduino really so we've taken an anode
which is actually invented by London
hack space
it's an Ethernet enabled Arduino as well
as having the standard Arduino and
everything else that you would expect on
do we know nor do we know standard
headers you've got an Ethernet device
already connected up first of all that
we've now got a connection back to our
service officer when we when somebody's
going to put them off ID card on there
we need to check that they're a member
and check to see how much money they've
got left on their card we then built a
shield to go on top of that we simple
AIT's our RF ID so RFID is on the
outside of the machine if we close that
we can have a quick look at that are
RFID just behind this little nice
laser-cut piece of wood here it is just
a nice simple RFID loop so it's held on
by magnets and because one of the things
we don't want to do is destroy the
machine in any way so if we could take
everything out without affecting it so
our shield connects us up to our RFID
but it also connects us up to the
multi-drop bus which is implemented on
this little board over here the reason
we've had to take it off onto a board is
that the multi-drop bus runs on 36 volts
and according to the specification you
have to optically isolate your the drop
bus from your device to make sure that
it doesn't affect the vending machine
controller or the vendor machine control
doesn't affect your device so on here we
have a number of optical isolating
devices they connect the bus to the
Arduino
and our final addition this was added on
a later date so it doesn't require this
to work there's a nice little display
that just tells you when you hold your
off ID card up there tells you who you
are and how much money you spent last
but not least is an LED indicator just
says whether a card has been scanned it
goes a nice blue color so can we see it
working we can indeed so if we close it
back up again and let it reboot
display show is ready but normally it
always is we hold a card against there
the light will come on it tells us that
Daniel because I've stolen Daniels card
for today and the reason I've got
Daniel's card is because the law of this
machine is too great now spent
my money for this month unfortunately so
pop the card on a machine type in what
we want so it's have a Twix for Daniel
and it blends out all done yum yum
they're going to let us see that no
that's mine now let's go back into the
machine again so what happens is the the
vending machine controller is constantly
polling all the devices that's connected
on the multi-drop boss so that's in our
case that's just the cash machine and
the cashiers device in other machines
that might be a note vendor it could be
an actual credit card device as well so
it pulls them just to see if it if they
need to do anything and when you put
your card on our device tells the
vending machine that somebody's
activated the card and it's ready to go
now can bend when you then choose
something to then so we chose a Twix the
vending machine controller tells us that
it wants to buy Twix and Asus if the
person can afford 50 P a normal Cassius
device if you bought one would has the
money stored on the card so it
authenticates to the card and knows what
the balance of the card is and will just
reply instantly with how much it can
have ours is connected to our hacks
based server Holly and that's Holly ham
what the credit limit on that user is if
they can afford 50 P well then let the
vending machine know that they can and
ask you to vend that as you saw it just
bend it out and let's just know that it
ended it and that's when we took the
money from the users balance or tell
Holly sort of stated the money from
users balance the cast of survice thing
goes back into its sleep state and
everything goes back to normal the venue
machine goes back to Pauling and all the
devices again so the link up with Holly
is actually quite interesting this is
part of all what's called our
instrumentation project in the hack
space all the various devices and hacks
base a hook took to install e in the
same way through a system called mqtt or
mosquito a mosquito is a way of sending
and receiving broadcast messages across
the network really simply they're on
their own
seperated Network they're not on the
main acts based network and they all
have their own different channels as it
were on that on the mosquito server so
when when we've ended when we're asking
to vent we're asking messages across
that system and then we're getting
messages back on that system as well
what what it does mean
we have certain services that can send
and receive messages as well so when
we've been we also send a message out
into it onto Twitter using one of our
channels so with the venom she doesn't
know how to tweet but we have a system
there's an athlete that receives mqtt
messages and then tweets whatever
whatever it's been told so so this that
just tweeted about Twix it just tweeted
about yeah we can indeed so we've got a
tweet here or the rocket boards are
available but not as nice daniel
purchased a 50 peak infection so
actually it's a generic it is very
generic it just say crisps it's a
crystal separate to confectionary and
the electronics are generally fairly
labeled so it's only because the
chocolate is often moved in and out of
different rows so we didn't label it and
they're all 50p and it doesn't always
tweet we have turned it often in recent
weeks because people arguing with it and
getting quite angry that it was it was
telling everybody they're eating on a
regular basis so we've we've turned the
tweet function off now but it's not
that's not the twitter of the whole so
yeah Holly RM our servers own Twitter
account tweet on a regular basis about
whether the hack space is open and
things like that so it's all that still
works it's just the vending machine
doesn't tweet anymore we were thinking
about getting a second vending machine I
can vending machine with a nut with
another cashless device but we think
that might be relatively easy because
apparently these vending machine
controllers and this will often live
famous last words
these vending machine crawlers are
fairly standard it should just be a
matter of replicating this and put in
any new machine
you
that's the on button so to test at any
point while you've got it open you have
to hold the button in and we ended up
having all sorts of devices just stuck
down here toward the button while we
were messing around with things and that
was the hardest part it really it's not
like a safety oh it's just so it's just
so turns off when you open the door and
it only turns on when you close the door
but also you wanted it on so we could
test with the door open